high breath yeah and i guess by that you
mean the kind of things that i wanted to
talk about
or maybe your persona and yeah that it
feeds into what you're talking about
yeah you know i remember being
sitting there one night uh at the improv
in l.a and
and stephen wright was really big then
and
you know steve was very slow and
monotone
but but so funny and i just thought he
was so funny and
i remember saying man i don't know
whether i should be fast or whether i
should be slow or
and and seinfeld said and i think you
just do
it every night and after 10 years you
have a style
and i'm like well i don't know about
that
but but jerry was right in that in that
like when we did the first blue collar
comedy
movie i had a joke in there
uh i was talking about a wood-burning
kid and and i would say
uh some about the back in the old days
people would inspect the toys to make
sure there was no way a child could
possibly get
hurt using that using that
and and when i watched it i thought
how i didn't realize i did that to hit
that one word
and go up and and
and i don't i hate to watch myself or
listen to myself but now i notice there
that somehow through just doing it that
i do
that that there's a you know there's a
i will hit certain words or pause a
certain way and it's
it's not a calculated thing it's just
kind of how i've learned to tell a story
i guess so it's something you kind of
noticed that got a response and then you
started to almost incorporate it more
into your performance yeah i would think
that's probably you know like uh
like uh i was talking to bob newhart one
time and i said
i said you know what you can do bob that
i'm so jealous about
is you can make people laugh without
saying anything
you could just that pause
and he said well i stole that from jack
benny
you know jack benny you know the guy's
your money or your life and benny
yeah has to pause to think about it yeah
and
and so yeah i think i think we do
learn that it's you learn as you're on
stage working out
oh shoot sometimes if i take a pause
people start laughing or if or if i get
a manic they start laughing or whatever
it is within your thing and i think
over time that's how your style develops
you know i'm sure it was that way with
kennison
screaming i mean i don't it probably
wasn't a plan
thing just one night
and people started bursting and he went
oh that could actually
become a punchline that and yeah that's
how your style develops